welcome to the hos discover Series in
this video we're dealing with chatter
and how to get rid of it there's a great
feature available on all hos lathes that
you may not be familiar with it's called
SSV SSV is short for spindle speed
variation and when it's activated it
increases and decreases spindle speed
continuously which can significantly
reduce the effects of
chatter let's start up our spindle at
2,000 RPM and let's turn on SSV our
settings have SSV adding and subtracting
100 RPM from our speed continuously
every 2
seconds and we can hear the spindle
speeding up and slowing down now we'll
turn out the lights and turn on a strobe
light flashing 2,000 times a minute now
we can see our Chuck rotating faster and
slower than our 2,000 RPM commanded
speed that's cool but what do you use
SSV
for well when difficult cutting
conditions cause chatter in your
workpiece SSV can help we all know
chatter is bad but what is Chatter
describing how chatter starts and
progresses during turning can get really
complex in essence chatter amounts to a
resonance that starts between the part
and and the cutting tool leading to a
vibration this vibration causes a rough
uneven cut on the part this uneven
surface causes the vibration to
intensify making the surface rougher
still causing the vibration to increase
again and on and on until the part is
screaming and the Finish is terrible now
the workpiece and the tool are vibrating
badly causing the cut to unload and load
back up many times a second spiking
cutting Force like an interrupted cut no
wonder it's
shrieking if it's resonance that gets
all of this started what if we could
stop this resonance from even beginning
that's exactly what SSV is designed to
do let's look at an illustration of how
SSV impacts chatter here we have a nice
steady low level resonance as our cut is
progressing
normally when we encounter poor cutting
conditions the resonance begins to
change and we get that escalating
vibration that we just
described this vibration will just keep
on increasing and increasing now we'll
turn on SSV the spindle speed is now
going up and down and that spindle is
spending very little time at that
resonance speed keeping it out of the
chatter zone so the vibration resulting
from the resonance has no chance to
progress into chatter
so how do I use this feature we use
setting 165 and setting 166 to drive
SSV in order to understand these
settings let's take a look at this graph
the middle line represents our commanded
spindle
speed SSV setting 165 controls spindle
speed
variation we're going to insert a value
of 150 here what this does is it causes
the spindle speed to increase by 150 RPM
and then decrease by 150
RPM on our graph that spindle speed
swing is represented by this blue
line so our value of50 yields a high RPM
of 1650 and a low RPM of 1350 as you can
see the total RPM range is 300
RPM SSV setting 16 66 controls the time
period and on our graph the distance
across the curves represents the time
for one cycle in our example we'll use a
value of
12 where each unit equals 0.1 seconds
the value of 12 gives a time period of
1.2 seconds to complete each of those
300 RPM
sweeps now that that we understand the
SSV concept A little let's look at what
SSV can do when we're cutting without
tail stock support we're going to turn
this 1.75 in diameter shaft and see
where the chatter
starts the shaft is held 7 in out at an
unsupported length to diameter ratio of
4:1 once we reach a diameter of 1.25 in
this is where we begin to see chatter on
the next pass at a diameter of 1.15 in
we're at a 6:1 LTD ratio which is well
pasted where we normally would need tail
stock support and indeed we have some
serious
chatter typically as the LTD increases
chatter also increases so let's cut a
fresh one of these at that same diameter
with SSV on let's see if it fixes the
problem we insert the M38 command in our
program to turn on SSV V we'll use the
SSV values from the earlier example we
had setting 165 set at 150 and we had
setting 166 set at
12 remember that gives us a 300 RPM
swing every 1.2
seconds we can see that the bar cut
using SSV has a much better
finish if we had to cut this part
without a tail stock which we know we
shouldn't SSV saves our part let's move
on to demonstrate how SSV can extend
your capabilities when cutting with tail
stock support we tried really hard to
find a combination of material and an
insert that would chatter during a tail
stock supported cut and what we found is
the st30 cut so well under normal
conditions it really didn't want to
chatter after several attempts using
smaller workpieces we ended up down at
a/ in diameter on a 10in long workpiece
with no chatter and a decent finish now
that's a 20 to1 length to diameter ratio
and in 1040 steel not the freest cutting
material out there we moved to much
larger material and we made the setup
less and less optimal until we found a
combination of tooling and material that
finally would shatter now let's see what
SSV can do for us on a couple of
compromised
setups first we cut this 3-in bar right
at the edge of the machine's length
envelope using compromised cutting
parameters and clamping we got shatter
major material and setup compromises
forced this part to ridiculous levels of
chatter and under normal circumstances
we would have stopped cutting long
before reaching levels of chatter like
this and we're not saying you should
expect SSV to cure chatter at this
absurd level yeah there is still chatter
on the SSV part but looking and
listening to the difference between the
two shows us that SSV made a a really
positive change and if you aren't
starting out with horrendous chatter
then SSV can often solve your
problem okay let's leave the realm of
the ridiculous for a more common set of
circumstances this time we're using a
2.25 in diameter mild steel shaft held
16 in out from the Jaws still with tail
stock support of course our tool
geometry is less than optimal with a
larger nose radius our slow feed rate is
spending a lot of time in the cut and
the support is coming from a less rigid
CNC Center all part of our recipe for
achieving
Chad with SSV off begin to get shatter
at a diameter of 1.12
in just to make sure we've got some
decent shatter going we'll take several
more Cuts until we're down around an
inch
diameter our test bar is now chattering
quite seriously the LTD ratio of this
setup is now 16 to1 now let's see how
this cut does when we turn SSV on
cutting again at a diameter of 1 in so
our setting 165 is equal to
125 and we have our setting 166 at 6
giving us a 250 RPM swing every 610 of a
second and again we can hear and we can
see the chatter has
disappeared the finish on the shaft
using SSV is significantly better than
the one running at one single speed some
people like to run with smaller values
than we do here like a 165 value in the
20 to 50 range combined with setting 166
numbers between 10 and 30 but here at
hos we found that the best starting
point for these two numbers is a setting
165 value between 100 and 200 RPM
combined with a setting 166 per period
value between 5 and 20 some
experimentation will probably be
necessary to find the best values for
your particular
part now we're going to take a quick
look at g96 and G50 two commonly used
g-codes that can interfere with the way
SSV functions under certain
circumstances we'll start with g96 which
is the constant surface speed command to
get a handle on g96 we need to
understand the concept of surface
footage here we have two bars One 7 in
in diameter and the other only 1 in in
diameter looking at the 7in bar let's
see how much distance we can cover
cutting for one
revolution in one revolution we cover a
distance 22 in long so one revolution
equals 22
in now looking at the 1in diameter bar
one revolution is cutting only about 3
in the 7in part is covering 7 times more
distance per Revolution than the 1in
part that means the 1-in bar needs to
rotate seven times faster to cover the
same
[Music]
distance now let's say we want to use
this insert and it cuts best at a
surface footage rate of 900 sfm or
Surface F feet per minute that's 900 ft
of material rotating past the cutter
every minute to get 900 surface fet per
minute on our 7in part we need to cut at
RPM but to get 900 surface feet per
minute down at a 1- in diameter we have
to crank that speed up to about 3,400
RPM yep 7 times faster so when our part
got seven times smaller our speed had to
get seven times faster now we know that
speed must increase as diameter
decreases and vice versa to keep surface
footage the same and that's exactly what
g96 does it adjusts spindle speed on the
fly to maintain a constant surface speed
at the tip of the tool when you're
facing apart for example spindle speed
increases constantly as the cut moves
towards the center so it's easy to see
how spindle speeds can get away from you
pretty
quickly so it would be good to have
control over the high speeds that g96
can generate and that's where G50 comes
in when used in conjunction with g96 G50
sets the fastest allowable speed within
a programmed operation the spindle can't
go any faster under any circumstances
G50 provides a fail safe and it's wise
to include it in your programs say we're
turning a heavier part and we're
concerned about high RPM reducing Chuck
grip force and potentially throwing the
part and we're not comfortable going any
faster than 2,000 RPM with this setup so
all we would do is set our G50 to 2,000
RPM now the spindle can't go above 2,000
G50 is often used in this way to keep
g96 commanded spindle speeds in
check okay let's recap and we'll see how
g96 and G50 can interfere with
SSV for this new example we'll use this
1 and 3/4 in bar now we know that g96
adjusts spindle speed to maintain
constant surface speed our program has a
g96 set to 775 this time which is
telling the spindle to maintain that 775
surface feet per minute our program here
has G50 set to 3,000 RPM again SSV is on
on and our setting 165 value is 200 with
200 added to the commanded spindle speed
our RPM for the first cut Peaks at 2,000
RPM as we continue to cut and that
diameter gets smaller of course the
spindle speed
increases the final pass is at just
under an inch in diameter now g96 is
attempting to push the spindle to
3,150 RPM
remember the spindle speed is being
limited to 3,000 RPM by the G50 command
so we have a problem the black line
Rising above the 3000 RPM ceiling
represents the part of the SSV range
that's being clipped the blue line below
this represents the only portion of the
SSV range that's doing anything so how
do we solve this problem there are only
three variables that we can change here
we don't want to increase the G50
setting because we're afraid of throwing
the part and we know our SSV settings
are allowing for a good finish so we
don't want to touch those that leaves us
with g96 as The Logical value to change
in this scenario we'll reduce the g96
setting from
775 down to 700 which still allows the
insert to cut
decently on our chart you can see the
g96 range drops down and now now our
Peak RPM with SSV is 2900 RPM we're
below our G50 limit and SSV is working
again through its entire
range how can I tell if g96 and G50 are
causing SSV not to function or to clip
easy you won't see the spindle RPM
change that much on the screen and you
also wouldn't hear the spindle changing
speed continuously remember if you can't
hear it working it probably isn't
working
here's an example of what it sounds like
when SSV is fully
functioning one more tip before we wrap
up you should pay close attention to how
SSV settings affect spindle load
starting with SSV values of 50 and 20 we
see the spindle isn't really working
very hard change those values to 110
twice the speed in half the time and now
the spindle load is at a Moder at level
increasing those values to
205 doubling and halfing our values
again the spindle is getting a real
workout these are very aggressive
settings there will be situations where
LTD ratio materials and cutting
parameters reach such an extreme that
even SSV will not be able to remedy the
chatter but there are also times it can
be the difference between completing a
job or not SSV is a valuable tool for
achieving the best finish on a difficult
material or setup thanks for watching
[Music]